everyone thinks he's like having a
breakdown when I saw the clip I was like
okay I rushed home I was hysterically
crying um Kanye West left Kim in tears
totally not okay let's rewind just a
little bit we're finally getting some of
the back story behind Kanye West's
bananas up here in sont en si live back
in May
thanks to Keeping Up with the
Kardashians here's how Kim broke it all
down with her friends but when I saw the
clip I was like okay I rushed home I was
hysterically crying so I go home he's
totally fine the thing is when he gets
ramped up you have to do it he can't
control it he can't let it go like a dog
but he loves being ramped up he's like I
feel powerful when I'm ramped up like I
don't want to be like so suppressed like
yeah I say crazy but I've always said
crazy but that's why I am Kanye I
totally respect Kim for standing by her
man
and she continued to defend him in a
confessional you guys check this out
Kanye is flavory comment he never said
that that was just the headline he said
slavery was 400 years if it's gonna be
another 400 years that sounds like a
choice to me he didn't say slavery is a
choice he was saying if you're gonna
still be in slave for another 400 years
then that's simple you know but all the
headlines just took
yeah that has a wife is really
frustrating to see the media take
everything and run with it
you guys just look at how her eyes are
moving around the room she was defending
him to every single producer in that
room that wasn't even a confessional I
mean but this could be a little bit of
revisionist history here's the clip from
TMZ for you to judge for yourself you
hear about slavery for 400 years from
400 years that's not like a choice like
he was there for 400 years and it's all
y'all you know like it's like we're
we're mentally in prison alright so what
do we think is Kim's defense real or
could this just be her saving face could
it be somewhere in between what we do
know is that Kim will always always be a
fierce defender of Kanye's right to say
whatever the hell he wants here's what
she told et over the summer after all
the TMZ ish went down I've seen him go
through a lot and he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that might get misinterpreted and
people don't see the context behind it
but I always know his heart obviously
there's gonna be a lot more to dig into
once the actual episode of Keeping Up
airs on Sunday but do you want to see
Kanye side of the story on the show I'd
be really interested to see his take I
guess we'll just have to wait and see
until then hit me up on Twitter with all
your kidney thoughts I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens see you next time
[Music]